alright hey everybody I'm miles I'm
backstage here with Zachary Quinto and J
Family Eddie who were you guys were
great on the show tonight that's so cool
it was awesome you got really into how
about a dire situation we're in here in
California is it as bad as everybody
saying it is it's worse yeah and we
didn't really get to get into that in
the show the pace of the show is pretty
quick but some of the data that we we
look at show that the total amount of
water in California has been actually
been in decline for for several decades
certainly since 2002 since we started
monitoring it by satellite in these last
three years have been catastrophic I
mean we've been losing trillions of game
8 trillion gallons of water per year
that's more than all 38 million
Californians use for domestic and
municipal water use have you been
drinking your 8 ounces a day stop just
like rats leaving a sinking ship right
how do you think it's gonna affect
migration here in California do you
think we're gonna you know it should but
but the truth is we'd love to live in
you know in dry arid climates they're
beautiful
right it's beautiful but there's no
water I think the larger problem is that
you know global warming is going to
affect migration and that's what we can
see if we look at the if we step back
and look at the larger issue at hand of
which this is certainly an integral part
but you know if you look at the western
ice shelves above Antarctica they're
right there they're irrevocably melting
to the point that the oceans are going
to rise to 1 to 6 meters in the next ten
years and that could displace up to 300
million people which is almost the
entire population of our country
vice just had a really is what I saw
which was so alarming and yet at the
same time at least it gives us the
information at least it's it's you know
irrefutable data that we can use to
calculate and modify our behavior
patterns as a civilization in the
interest of our self-preservation and
that's the thing that I feel like
everybody is being very cavalier about
in terms of preparedness and the ability
right dealing with these issues
well your point in the show about
government's not being prepared in the
things that zach is talking about so
sea-level rise right changes in the
frequency of droughts and flooding
global change global warming yeah it's
it's a completely different future that
that we're facing and people love to
politicize it right so it's like it's
the the perceived left who is you know
banging the drum of climate change and
environmental necessity for this kind of
attention and it's people on the extreme
right who are like not burying their
heads in the sand and not even
acknowledging it the reality is that
it's not a political issue it says right
it's a it's an issue of our species in
the survival of our it's happening it's
very logical
I'd say thank you so that's that's an
excellent point and I think in in just a
matter of a couple of decades all these
issues will make themselves you know
they looks press themselves it'll be
abundantly clear and so this you know
debate about whether it's happening or
not happening
it'll be laid to rest and it's
unfortunate because it'll be laid to
rest in you know in ways that will be
catastrophic and will displace people
anywhere and that we're not prepared for
we're not prepared for
we were poking fun on the show tonight
about some of the half-assed measures
that California has been taking in a
response to this drought those measures
so if they were admittedly modest right
and like we were talking about a little
bit earlier
our government has given us the space to
act on our own and we're not stepping up
oh speaking of acting on our own I have
a drought quiz and professor all right
exactly we have this is from the
Southern California Public Radio they
put it together all right so which would
save more water fee do you want to
answer separately or together you guys
can put your minds together or mines fur
anyway shall we
a eight for fewer quarter pound
hamburgers or be shaped two minutes off
of our showers which would save more
water
I think the burgers - burgers burgers
that is correct you guys nice work
confessor no four ounces of beef two
causes because of the amount of grass
that house have to eat which is its
alfalfa which takes a huge amount of
water yeah did you know that one burger
takes six hundred and seventy five
gallons of wine yeah that makes sense
next question five five fewer t-shirts
this year or convert your lawn to native
plants and grasses convert your lawns
native plants grass absolutely good
should you put a brick in your toilet
tank to displace water
not that kind or drink less soda by a
half a liter per week I don't know brick
in your toilet tank you shouldn't drink
so soda anyway right but half a liter a
week I would have to say putting a brick
in your toilet would save more water in
the end it does yeah you're absolutely
right yeah good reach but is a good job
so you take your car to a water
efficient car wash or put a cover on
your pool whoa okay let's think about
this
under efficient carwash that means that
they're recycling
that's really cool the cover in the pool
means that they're you're limiting the
evaporation right so I think you should
do both you should know if you have a
pool and you're yeah you don't have to
cover it if you like the both I'm gonna
go with the sea all of the emotion
perfect but actually putting cover on
your pool with say more water than going
to a water efficient car wash versus
watching your car to drive okay so in in
area like Southern California that
doesn't have any water you should just
forget about Washington yeah kind of
right okay what about installing water
saving faucets at home or cutting
alcohol consumption by one beer a week
what are saving faucets at home versus
cutting alcohol one beer a week one beer
week if every a week because a lot of
this process into the beer but you think
about a water saving thing but the beer
money the viewer defer to I mean I kind
of gave it pretty heavy hint there but
you guys are correct now no one but it's
pretty close might as well just stay
like all of these things all of these
things are there real good
put a cover in your pool and have two
piers totally well I mean if you have
leaky faucets right you should be fixing
yeah right absolutely
but it's a good point to think about the
water footprint of course like the what
and we don't really know the water
footprint of the things that we drink
the things that we eat 400 cows to make
hamburger are we gonna start talking
about our water footprint the way we do
about our footprint yeah I also and in
effect what we really need to be
thinking or feeling
no no no we should be thinking about an
overall environmental footprint it's a
you know those metrics are really really
difficult to figure out
so the carbon footprint that's gotten a
lot of that's made a lot of progress we
should be doing a water footprint or
maybe we should be thinking about some
kind of overall environment all in irons
destroying footprint yes yes right earth
eating planet eating so exactly last
question last one last one all right
drink coffee or drink tea what saves
more longer coffee coffees dehydrating
it's getting late drink coffee
then you okay I think to grow the tea
right I'm thinking maybe more water to
grow those beans wait wait so what are
you doing with coffee tea coffee you
drink more coffee or drink more tea
what's the question which do you drink
more which would save more water if you
drink coffee or drink tea again I defer
let's do it together
I say coffee you're gonna drink more
coffee okay yeah yeah congratulations
you just killed the planet oh that's
dirty all right you ready one pot of
coffee is 220 gallons of water versus
one pot of tea is only 25 [ __ ] I really
feel the glitter
mind blown I don't like coffee or tea so
I'm gonna give you guys straight A's
anyway you did so good thank you so much
for joining me thank you professor Jay
family idea zachary quinto thanks for
joining saying
you